this is the please be with you welcome
to the D show I'm Eddie our host and
we're going to be talking about in this
episode the proper way to interpret the
verbatim we've got the car on with my
next guest because there's a lot of
people I'm sure we just open up the
crowd and you've probably seen this and
they read an English translation which
is not the crown the crown is in the
original Arabic which has been preserved
tamper free temper proof it's a living
miracle for anyone who's sincere who
comes at it sincerely looking at it
objectively will see that there's no way
that this hat in his book could have
come from anyone other than the crater
that happens in earth revealed over 20
years 23 years and there's a proper way
of interpreting it and we're going to
find out what that proper way is here in
the D show with this week's special
guest Oh anywhere this is the
this is the thing you know this is the
danger this is the welcome back to the D
show special guest in the studio
assalamu alaikum peace be with Allah
alaikum Salaam Baalak not a light out of
what a cattle another ad how you doing
hamdullah haridas always pleasure to
visit Chicago and visit the dentro
always pleasure to have you make sure
you stopping all the time when you're
here yes definitely it's my pleasure to
children you know often when we quote
this ayah from the verbatim word of God
the Koran that killing one innocent
being is as you if you killed the whole
of humanity saving one innocent being is
as if you save all of humanity now I get
bewildered when you have a lot of not
yet Muslims out there and people who
kind of you know at some would a would a
monovalent agenda they basically want to
twist some of these ayahs and other
verses from the Koran to try to make
Islam look very violent to make it look
barbaric and that brings me kind of what
we're going to be talking about today
people interpreting took took her on in
whatever way they want so have you had
this scenario happen to you so will
quote this verse and the guide will say
no no it doesn't actually this is meant
for that time this plan I'm thinking
like hold on this person is actually if
they took a little more time sincerely
to study this time they'll see as the
truth right instead of just increasing
their their hate for it you know because
they're interpreting it according to
some haters interpretation will you
comments on this hamdulillah salat wa
salam ala rasoolillah machado la la la
hora de haut de aquila ashhadu anna
muhammadan
though wara solo you touched on a very
sensitive and another important
phenomenon and in the Muslim world right
now is the people having the carriage to
interpret the Quran without even finding
out how the Quran should be interpreted
and deceived if I may use the word here
as an English verb Abu Bakr also did at
one time was asked about the meaning of
averse and who is Abu Bakr Siddiq
someone who was like the shade of
rasulullah sallallahu selim and he
didn't know this is the companion now
this is like a best friend of the last
year animation karma yes and the first
leader of the Muslims after the demise
of Rasulullah sallallahu Leo Selim and
the person kind of said to him what do
you mean you don't know it's what do you
mean evil I said what earth would carry
me what heaven would shade me if I say
about a verse in the Quran without
knowledge
Ahmad Macabre belong one day he was
delivering a sermon and he quoted the
verse in surah abasa wather keratin were
a bear fruit and a bear he said i'm
elfelfa Hadar of nya
as for the fruits we know what the
fruits is you know grapes and so forth
bananas what is he lab a lab is not a
common Arabic word and then he looked at
his companions and he said the people in
front of him and I said what may adorn
work and what was going to hurt the
armour that you don't know what that
means and I'm not going to say about it
about it because I don't know what it
means for we're having a trend in the
Muslim world right now especially
amongst the youth and it's a very
alarming trend when somebody grabs the
most off and he stands out the
in front of the people and he explains
the verse based on his understanding
these brothers do not realize that
before this verse arrived him arrived to
him reached a me Annie that's what I
mean before he actually ended up
reciting it and reading it
this verse passed by the prophet
sallallaahu listen this verse passed by
the companions may allah be pleased with
them
this verse passed by the second-best
generation the third best generation he
needs to go back and find out how they
understood it but if someone says look I
know English I'm competent I pick up two
different two three different
translations I can read English and I
mean I can decipher it for myself I got
it I got a PhD maybe the Quran ad was
revealed in 23 years altogether and some
month and a lot of the verses in the
Quran have what is called suburbanos uli
a reason for its revelation we
understand that the reason for the
revelation is not what determine our
understanding or all overall
understanding of it but the overall
meaning is what determines understanding
of the verb determines our understanding
of the verse but yet the reason for the
revelation grants you a criteria that
can lead you towards the proper
understanding of the verse this is what
the scholars say lays ellebra before
sources sever weather can be all Moomin
loves a shared or the important thing is
I think we we should say this and and
and addressing this matter dear brothers
dear sisters the most famous book of
tafseer out there and I want a question
asked that the viewers this question
your viewers this question what is the
first book that springs out in your mind
when I asked you about FCS is it Nuka
thieves yeah no question even though it
look as if no Kathy came after it
Nigeria ee ee actually is more knowing
in the Muslim world amongst the scholars
in particular but why I'm not a fear
because if no kathira followed that
methodology he would explain the Quran
with the Quran the Sunna explains the
Quran the Sahaba explains the Quran the
second best and the third best
generation explained the Quran then you
go after the language this is the
methodology that is followed if you jump
into the language you're going to get in
trouble because you have to follow that
and then hopefully we'll explain more of
this now I mentioned a lot of
non-muslims doing this who are not
really sincerely looking for the truth
they're looking to oppose the truth but
then you also met you've got a lot of
Muslims doing this so I mean both are
being ignorant to the fact actually are
none Muslim at least you can say come on
yeah you don't even know alone we'll put
on the signs of the but now now you're
spunky a Muslim you got an okay so we're
going to again before we leave what are
the steps again okay
the Quran explains the Quran yes the Sun
next in that they have to follow that
sequence that's and that's how look at
you didn't go and open any verse in the
proper way now this is how he does it
say the Quran explains the Quran
rasoolallah Holly SLM explains the Quran
the sahabi explains the Quran the second
best and the third best generations
explained the Quran then you can go
after the Arabic Lam done that's it
that's it okay we'll be right back he's
going anywhere no I'm not going to leave
when I come back you'll be gone empty
chair you don't stick it back a little
anywhere when I embraced Islam from that
day on I knew I never wanted to drink
another drink in my life I never wanted
to smoke I never wanted to harm my body
because I realized that it was a
blessing you know to be able to see life
from the perspective of Islam because
it's like a lens that clarifies life for
you and so I started seeing the clarity
of life and I said this is what I've
been looking for all my life now all I
have to do is live up to it subscribe
right now
and enjoy all of the content that we're
going to be putting out for you thank
you peace be with you so I'm like back
here on the Deen show so a sister says
look I don't have to wear hijab she
picks up she said I don't see the word
hijab in the Quran right she's reading
Yusuf Ali is this an example of jumping
somewhere where you're not going
according out what she said absolutely
the hijab is in the Quran this is to
begin with you know we have two verses
crystal-clear she says hij B H I J a B
is not there well this is now she's
going to go after you know the Quran e
groups that says the religion is only
the Quran who said that the Quran and
Sunnah and in the Quran Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala says whatever the messenger
commands you do you need to do but let
me give you an example of a companion
the prophets Allah Allah Allah Allah few
hadith Muslims so highly Muslim example
live now I'm living as he said learn the
quran from for abdul live nematode was
number one on the list then Wilde said
Malibu - I forgot oh babe niqab is the
second so those are for the liveness
road one day he was asked about a verse
in Surat for Surat office cholera banner
I met Kenneth Netanyahu eaten at night a
unifier of Nevada New Guinea the meaning
of the verse o Allah you made us live
twice died twice what is that so the
Companions asked him yet never showed
what does it mean
he is were talking about a companion you
know what he said to facilitate baqara
the verse in surat al-baqara explains it
so he went after the first source now
the Quran explains the Quran what verses
is he referring to an idol baqara how
did it came attack funa billahi wa kunu
ma am what and here consumed by you me
to come to my here come here it is how
did you disbelieve in Allah when you
were dead and he given you life and then
he's going to make you die and he's
going to give you a life again so those
are the four times that are mentioned
sort of answers so the point I'm trying
to make the Quran explains the Quran and
this is where a result Salalah Hannah
Selim spend time with debris lady we
read hadith it not best that every
Ghibli would come and review with the
Prophet salah salem the quran not review
the the memorization of the Quran you
dare issue whole Quran teaches him the
Quran a lemma who Shadid alcoa the
mighty one taught him the quran meaning
gibreel al salat wa salam
so no so solemn would ask gibreel about
verses that he does not understand so
the first place we need to go to is the
Quran now next who learned the Quran
Sunnah Rasul Salah Salomon that's why
look at the books of the seer
I'm sorry in the books of hadith you
always find a book in the myths of
amongst the books of hadith gettable
liman kitab Wilhelm Keitel Bhutto he'd
Katie Abu Saleh
Kate Abu Sokka Katara will had thetable
jihad you always find a local wa k Tara
would have seen the book of taxis well
this is a explanation of the Quran
certain verses that their compiler of
the hadith would bring an explanation of
the Quran so how dare you go and explain
the Quran without going back to the
Sunnah without coding this another
something you really sound ridiculous if
you say we don't need the Sunnah if you
say we're quran 'yes that's what the
heavy one is is saying oh that's exactly
what the heaven directly saying that she
is indirectly saying that she's saying
that the verse was revealed to her she
believed came to her not to las olas
illallah wa sallim have you heard of
these groups they cut the quran e so you
ever had a discussion with someone like
this yeah I had I have a couple of
YouTube videos out there were they
really insulting and I had one of them
actually calling me on my show at one
time they remember that let's talk about
it show yeah and you know he kept
arguing with me and then I was his
argument give us an example well his
argument that everything is in the Quran
we do not need this one then I started
asking him
how do we pray they can you find this in
the Quran how many salons how should we
pray how should we what about the 2.5
percent the mandatory zakat bring this
out from the Quran so at the end when
you know when they are very empty
because they use evidence taken out of
context then subhanAllah that was a live
show he was on the air with me and I
didn't want to sound you know I don't
want to insult him and uh normally when
you go into debate when you lose your
temper that means you lose even if you
have that if you have the correct
position on an issue then I asked him
are you a Muslim his name is Ahmed are
you a Muslim Ahmed he said yes can he
tell me what makes you a Muslim you know
what he said a shadow la ilaha illallah
wahdahu la sharika lah and he stopped do
you believe that what about the other
shadow know Muhammad Rizal that that's a
bit yeah
so what I'm trying to say there are good
Muslims out there who may not have that
extreme trend but yet when they cancel
out the Sunnah when they explain the
Quran that's what you're doing you're
saying that verse came to you before
Rasul Allah Allah Allah
Rasul Allah salem taught his companions
his companions they learned it not best
by even a cop I named some of them a
blind Nam lived alas they they were
there when the verse was revealed and
when they did not understand the verse
they would go back to the prophet
sallallaahu Salomon asked him about it
so you need to go to find out what the
companion how the companion understood
the verse now Abu Bakr understood it
then after that these companions they
taught their students Mujahid for
example would say that I reviewed the
Quran and the explanation of the Quran
twice without live nabis which item job
and others then you can go to the
language but you go just for the
language we hear a lot of of brothers
going out there and explaining the Quran
using the language that is dangerous the
language is one of the tools but it
comes in that sequence what do you tell
a non-muslim or opponent of Islam who
has he throws you
we talked about you know the verse work
anyone in this human being and then they
throw all these let's do this actually
there is actually there is actually a
say look it's very very no no girl how
do you not like this there is a verse in
surah at-taubah which means what kill
the infidels would you find them sit for
them that's the the famous verse they
throw their up here without the sooner
you've never been be able to grasp the
understanding of this verse a lot of
people don't notice the explanation of
this verse is not the Quran is not in
the Quran he cannot find an explanation
for this verse in the Quran the
explanation for this verse in surah and
soon NNSA give us the worst explain the
explanation that the carabao was
surrounded with idols the Kaaba the
house of Allah was surrounded with idols
a result assalam could not even perform
his head without cleansing the the Kaaba
from these idols now a results illallah
SLM received the beginning of a chapter
in the Quran Kolubara a Toba where allah
subhanaw taala said to the messenger of
allah go and give them a declaration you
have four months to vacate the kaaba for
months to the vaquita now we need to pay
attention to this that the arabs always
had a problem fighting in inside the
Kaaba inside the cab somebody may be
killing another person or somebody would
kill the father of another person I
would go sit inside the Kaaba for a year
he cannot be touched they have to wait
for him until he comes out so now a
results illallah wa salim sent Ali bin
Abi Talib Raja lon huh to make that
declaration to the people in Mecca
listen you have four months to free the
Kaaba take your idols out move out after
that we are in a state of war you are
combatant you are combatant now now we
when we understand this verse kill the
infidels when you find them why would
you find them because what if they are
still in the cabin you're allowed to
fight them there snipe them shoot them
whatever it is so this is how you
understand these verses in a context of
a combating
oh so this is in combat yes but where do
you find that explanation in the Quran
this is bandhasana in court in the
Sierra
the last photography of the robot salah
salem we take a break we'll be right
back this exciting episode and indeed
show don't go anywhere
subscribe right now and enjoy all of the
content that we're going to be putting
out for you thank you peace be with you
so I'm like back here on the D show
we're talking about the proper way of
understanding and interpreting the car
and it's not like people of other faiths
they don't have this system you seem
like you know for instance our brothers
in Christianity again not to just to
hurt or insult anybody's but you see
this it's common like you ask one
individual about a particular topic they
have you have ten in a room you have
eleven different opinions right because
there's no set system you don't have
everything preserved it's not
authentically documented it's a lot of
guesswork here it's not guesswork
everything is preserved that's one of
the miracles of Islam mechana can I tell
you something very interesting the
difference between the people who follow
the truth and the people who follow any
falsehood
you name it whether it is good whether
this [ __ ] whether it is bida you name it
any falsehood which is conflicts or
contradicts the truth I will hot the
people of the truth and memorize this
dear viewers yeah at a Kaduna to my
yesterday Luna to my Attica dune they
look for the evidence then they
formulate I believe the other group is
the opposite they formulate a belief
yeah at at the Doudna some master de
Lune then they look for an evidence to
justify their beliefs hmm
you're getting that yes so when you
approach the Quran with the correct
beliefs I'm going to tell you a story
please and that story was mentioned in
the very earth ee again I love Abu Bakr
Siddiq I love him dearly
y'all gather us with Abu Bakr
of man Denali and the rest of the Sahar
one day laughter afterlife now beside
when Joe Bayless the narrator fee even
inevitable yani sahi aha Harlan
Abubakar one day stopped by the Jewish
school where Jews in Medinah are
teaching you know the Torah so he found
a very famous scholar of the Torah
sitting down whose name is Finn house
Furcal so did approached him and he said
why why you like a f'n has Aslam
woe to you often has become a Muslim in
naka muleta Ala Moana and you know that
Muhammad is a true messenger from Allah
he came confirming what you have become
a Muslim you know what fan hasit were
not winnable
I'm not going to believe in a God who
makes usually Haram on us and he accepts
usually xuxa
that's blasphemous statement what is he
referring to he's revealing to a verse
in the Quran Mandela tu caja carbon
Hassan ANOVA hula-hula - kathira who
soever Lin's Allah a goodly loan
Allah will multiply that one for him so
he's so you know sometimes he here these
brothers coming out with this with this
verse that al-qaeda is not important the
hate is not important what is the
problem of in house fin house approach
the Quran with a corrupt belief system
corrupt at either
he believes that Allah has a human huh
you know that that's the issue that's
the issue of that with us and our
brother you know from Christianity and
Judaism is the concept of God they
believe in a God but the concept is
distorted like the verse Allah created
the heavens and they say Allah created
the heavens and the verse in six days
and what did he do in the seventh day
Rus less does Allah rest no that's why
the Quran comes in and so loud cough
well Akkad hipness Emirati well although
I know who my VCT I am in one on a
salami loop I created the heavens and
the earth and what's between them in six
days and no even sign of fatigue
happened to me Allah is negating that
that is not correct
so Allah created the creation and here
it's creating the human an Angels
Council come and count that's what we
have in the old test and then and
distorted of course versions of it so
now the point here is when you approach
the quran without knowing the names and
the attributes of allah subhanahu allah
is you going to reach that conclusion
yeah because the obvious meaning of the
verse yes eliza allies accepting new
zuri that if you give him alone he's
going to multiply it for you meanwhile
can we do this if you give me a loan can
we do that No yeah so let me finish the
story quickly
Abu Bakr hit him slapped him actually
because he couldn't take it you know
it's it's not right so he won't ride
away to the Prophet Allah ceramics
complaining about Abu Bakr Siddiq again
it's about what can sit there then the
prophets allah salla mask of a walk why
did you do this Arabic we shouldn't be
doing this they see they are rasulallah
o Messenger of Allah he said this about
Allah soprano they said that Allah is
poor and we are rich he's making he's
asking us for a loan and he's going to
accept usury and meanwhile he you know
he it's it's unlawful for us to deal in
usury fin has said no I did not say that
he's basically saying that Abu Bakr is
like Jibreel Ali Salam comes down with
the Virgin surah al-imran la caída Samia
allahu taala ladina Khalu in allaha
fatima wanna know omnia Allah has heard
the statement of those who say that
Allah is poor and they are rich we will
write this sanic to Mahalo at laguna
lombija a live in to some sum up what I
what I'm trying to say is one of the
prerequisite for you to approach the
Quran to explain the Quran is not the
Arabic language rather it is the proper
belief system
Ikeda to heed because of your approach
the Quran lacking a key the lack into
heat you're going to reach a lot of
wrong conclusions with a lot of the
verses what if someone says look for the
person who's not Muslim so obviously
that person doesn't have a correct
belief at that time but he's looking at
how should that person approach that
that has no familiarity with the system
how should they you know if they're
sincere if they're looking for the truth
what
is that the criteria that is still the
criteria but that person needs to know
that the quran based on verse al Imran
has two types of categories
crystal-clear versus yes an ambiguous
verses who led Angela like al-kitab I
mean who I attune mahkumat on who normal
kita
he should go after these crystal clear
verses as for the ambiguous one you need
to go to a scholar fest LOL a decree in
kuntum Litella moon go and ask those who
have the knowledge of the Quran of the
Sunnah of the Sahaba if you do not if
someone says why are those ambiguous
verses there look at what is up either
what is a bid what is the concept of up
in the Quran all of the Puranas arcade
all the karana stop it what is al-qaeda
is the staple Hubbert and fiddle arm you
see art either is that you execute the
command of Allah and that you believe in
anything that you're told in the Quran
and the Sunnah without any doubt so the
ambiguous for they believe for you to
believe are you going to believe because
before you approach the Quran you should
have already established who's Allah you
really stablish that Allah is
all-knowing allah subhanaw taala is all
wise you already settle that case now
whatever Allah tells you it's like
before you go to a doctor right like in
my solana here before you go to a doctor
you go and look for the credential right
oh he's a Harvard I don't know if there
is a middle school middle school Harvard
but he's this is it when you go there
okay I want you to take that poison and
drink it you're going to drink it right
so we settled that's why that's what
partly days that's what's to Hades
that's what belief system is before you
approach the Quran you should have this
already in place and established so that
whatever you were to you know I know we
have to close but very quickly you know
the hadith regarding what if you have a
cup in front of you huh and I'm mosquito
or a fly you know the hadith right
yep the other wing listen if you wanna
drink it you can throw it away and go
and get another drink but what if you're
in the desert and this is the only drink
available for you okay a lot of people
say don't say this to non-muslims you're
going to say what drinking flies it had
a hover this is the information came to
you through revelation prove it you get
that German scientists going on
doing some lab they did someone yes some
lab work on it and what happened Eddie
what happened they found out that there
is a remedy in the other wing that's why
you need to dip that both wings inside
there is a disease and the remedy for
that disease
now Muslims say ah this is a good one
now this is a good one now that's not
how you deal with the Quran no no that's
not how we deal with it all right so
what let's recapping there's a system
first what are you for the Muslim now
but we got 30 seconds first one is Quran
by Quran or onyx even before that you're
sincere wanting to know correct belief
before you approach the Quran you must
have al-qaeda belief system you must
have to hate you must have a good
understanding yeah off half of your
belief system did one
the Quran explains the Quran don't don't
don't don't pass any of that here the
Quran explains the Quran rasool allah
wahda wa salim explains the Quran the
Sunnah hadith the tradition of the
prophets Allah salem the Sira of the
Prophet sallallahu wasallam then the
Sahabi because the Sahaba was there when
that verse got recited another and when
they didn't understand it they would go
and ask a result o Allah Sahaba passed
on the knowledge passed off the Quran
the Sunnah that have sealed the hadith
f22 second best and the third test
generation that is number four after
that he can go to the Arabic language
but what happens we have people jumping
into the Arabic language disregarding
those four okay license anything other
time ever offered it for the for the not
yet Muslims the non-muslims who open up
and start throwing verses out there try
to discredit Islam what you tell them
non-muslims please the Quran is very
special the Quran was revealed 23 years
not like the Torah not like the gospel
and for every verse there is a reason
for revelation almost almost
now you need to be aware of the criteria
the verse was revealed because of and
that will structure your understanding
of the verse thank you very much thank
you a colossal orchid and there you have
it the proper way to interpret the car
ad before you quote a verse out of
context before you try to interpret it
on your own
you follow these rules and that's how
you get to the truth and one important
point before that is coming to it with
sincerity this is so important very
important and I hope that you got the
benefit subscribe right now if you
haven't already so you can get the next
show delivered directly to you we'll see
you next time
peace be with you salami subscribe right
now and enjoy all of the content that
we're going to be putting out for you
thank you
peace be with you so I'm like